en voyant dans cauchemar en cuisine on a
retrouvé un chauve qui avait envie de
mettre des coups de boule à tout le
monde et cette fois je parle pas de
zinédine zidane mais bien de philippe
etchebest il est encore tombé dans un
restaurant de gens très endetté et qui
congèle tous leurs plats et ça ça lui
plaît pas de ouf
whitera comme un bon tu fais tu on a
fait la connaissance d'amande à la
cogérante une anglaise dont on
comprenait pas toujours les phrases
j'essaie quand va pas manger bien gétaz
de l'avant en savès on veut ton parti
monter ton parti monter oui et qui
avaient des poseurs de jane birkin
j'ai une mesquine philippe a essayé de
motiver un maximum pour améliorer la
situation mais c'était pas sain pour les
restaurateurs vu qu'en plus tous les
clients du resto c'était de sacrés
poucave on attend finalement philippe
amène le cuistot au marché pour lui
faire réaliser que c'est pas mal du tout
les produits frais il lui apprend à
faire à manger du coup ça le met de
bonne humeur mais toute façon le patron
on sait déjà qui sait voilà en gros
c'était ça hier dans cauchemar en
cuisine on en a d'autres et que on à la
barre de philippe etchebest
on continue parce que ça a beaucoup
baissé hier il mâche pas ses mots aussi
dans cauchemar en cuisine et c'est vrai
que ils jouent les tarbais vont pas se
mentir vous personne en a marre non cela
vous aimez bien mais oui puisque ça sans
lui a pas d'émission là oui c'est vrai
que les gens aiment c'est le voir
gueuler se le voir se déchaîner
doit-on avoir ton super non le oui non
oui pas joui moi il me saoule et un
petit peu moins ah oui sinon après moi
j'aime bien le personnage parce que il
dit les choses négatives et c'est comme
ça qu'on progresse après si on l'enlève
enfin je veux dire c'est bien c'est
comme ça c'est le plus d'émissions je
veux dire c'est comme des rêves syrie
n'y a pas d'émission d'euro c'est comme
si on enlève des boulettes dans le
couscous
non mais c'est vrai qu'il fait c'est
important qu'ils soient comme ça après
on aime c'est parce qu'elle est dans le
couscous sont des questions
baala
non à l'est de moscou c'est bien des
boulettes c'est dans ton slip cas des
capteurs est justement là le souci c'est
que les gens ne retiennent que le
négatif
et quand on regarde vraiment les
missions qu'on s'y intéresse vraiment et
qu'on la regarde pour de vrai parce que
je sais pas si tout le monde l'a vu eh
ben on se rend compte que cette personne
arrive aussi à faire ressortir les
sentiments des personnes et qu'on les
voit sous un autre angle
et c'est pas juste d'être négatif il ya
aussi énormément de positif et c'est
pour ça qu'on adore ça eh bien elle est
positif c'est là les carrefours
allégations alors c'est vrai que youtube
est il mâche pas ses mots dans cauchemar
en cuisine il est dur parfois regarde
maggio de pascal on arrête le service
j'en ai eu un des niveaux très bas appel
à j'en conclus que c'est nul à chier
vous avez 72 ans et sa femme 303 genre
critères je vous en mets 10 de plus qu'à
travailler dans un restaurant étoilé toi
ouais ça soit possible
insupportable pages on voit plus vous
j'ai pété un câble
voilà ils font son signal
c'est dur c'est dur mais comment dire
the voice qui sont trop ne le jury on ne
dit rien et là on le dit qu'il est trop
qu'il était dur mais faut savoir jamais
comment faubourg on place le curseur
mais non mais c'est vrai les joueurs
accèdent on est malheureusement arrivé
au bout d'histoire
j'adorais cette émission l'ordinaire
pour vous et votre ex actuel voilà parce
que moi j'adore cette émission j'adore
philippe etchebest voilà et du pays
basque comme comme jean pascal et moi
voilà ces démissions que j'adore
malheureusement c'est malheureusement
c'est trop cramé les ficelles sont trop
grosses ils ne diffusent est normal et
ne dit plus un mot tu ne sois pas dit
avant par la prod souvenez vous la faire
nous qui la semaine dernière et la main
tandis qu'ils aient quelque chose c'est
pas congeler si ces congés hissé de tous
avant que ça alors trop préparé vous
trouvez que c'est trop préparé si on
vous avez des couacs rami ont cramé
recracher eia patrice laffont qui a dit
c'est normal pour une émission de
cuisine oui je dis bravo
magnifique magnifique
il a attendu d'être dans mon émission
pour faire des vannes de merton
[Applaudissements]
attendu de tous mes côtés pour faire ça
bravo patrick colle sans papa vont pas
s'apaiser alors philippe mathieu mais
adore tous alors que tous les produits
soient servis frais a bien sûr on n'est
pas chez benhaim d'écouter de regarder
j'ai déjà vendu chez vos joueurs
partiront donc on est sur des produits
frais j'imagine puisent leur eau douce
et son épouse vos nuits fraîches son
camp je n'ai crise est là mais c'est
quand je mets tout l'indiqué dois
énormément les gens demandent pas
elle indiqué le vénérable indiqué dans
le monde ici non pas la mutinerie qui
sera pas 80 je précise je vais vue tout
est alors je vous ai vu douter
faut il alors suivre de la bouche est
fermée dans ces l'asean et misogynes que
j'aime parce qu'effectivement il ya des
plats pour pourrait faire affective
c'est réaliste
lui il est très sympathique et j'en ai
pas marre de tout c'est vraiment le la
seule façon pour moi de parler cuisine
avec le reste ça ne m'intéresse pas du
tout et les plats sont accessibles
contre 20 une pizza on sait tout sur les
pizzas même bien sûr bon bah moi vous
avez vu sur ses vrais amis et patrice
laffont s'est pas peur de pillages sera
l'info du jour